hello freak bitches but then to find out
it's an actual movie with Jodie Foster
is like wouldn't hide it actually cut
reviews how did Jodie Foster get sucked
into this fucking movie like she looks
great by the fifty years old this year
at the Oscars were a son wow she looks
phenomenal her skin and her they're
tight like she's crossed some damn know
that the noise she makes was Jodie
having sex chicks are just coming over
and eat her now come on over
that's a poached egg come on get so I'll
be a fly on the wall yeah she I don't
know she have a baby or anything or boy
girlfriends yeah isn't it funny that
that's like a big issue like whether a
chick is a lesbian by the way she talks
no but the thing is a woman like here's
the issue here's the legit s you for
real a woman like Jodie Foster can come
out of the closet and still play
someone's wife no problem no one has a
problem with it right if Tom Cruise and
I'm not saying Tom Cruise is gay but if
Tom Cruise was gay and he came out of
the closet
and then wanted to do a movie where he
was making out with a share so it's over
that's that's reality I'm United I
believe I mean I shouldn't say it's
reality because I'm basing it on my own
personal feelings of how it would go
well they would go down it might go down
differently but I think that you know
the people who do polling for
politicians and stuff like you know that
I mean you'd be amazed at how irrational
voters are finding out one little thing
about somebody's past can really sway an
election so people are very you know for
the most part people are pretty
conservative in their ideology yeah it
doesn't seem to be an issue when you're
women that are coming out it's like we
don't really have that much of a problem
with that there's not there's no like
there's not a situation I really think
it's all your bump and moths and you're
making out yeah there's a neediness to
cock
tell me what I need yeah and also
there's also the stigma of disease and
all that so that comes with it right
with the gay side yeah what if they're
just in a jerking off each other clean
staring each other in the eye they look
in the Wow look it away what are you
worried about over you see you dick for
a second as a goof I'm gonna jerk it off
I've been shaving around my dick because
they say it makes my dick look bigger
but I'm not convinced give me an opinion
I mean I want you to be objective let me
give it a look I give it a look I don't
think it looks any bigger that looks a
lot bigger I'm telling you it doesn't
look can I be honest with you it doesn't
even when you choke you with this you
look like you should have hopes just
suck it and they wouldn't even feel bad
it would just go all the way in your
mouth I mean I bet would even try it
right now I'll bet mouth you mean you
don't think you could feel it we need to
try need to do another Mikey yeah
absolute Oni in the base all right this
was the characters names to remember
Mikey whatever was my key and my mom who
was Kelly Kirsten yeah she was great